2017ねー
遊戯を
なんだっけ
世界展開 world championship 2010ならの世界で一番強いと
決める大会の優勝者
誰かご存知でしょうか世界のそのものと世界のトップに君臨した人はこの人です
どうか
ばは今のところ世界チャンプ嘘
今のところ来年まで待ってくれちゃう現段階での世界チャンピオン
づらくんです
den
思って俺裏側守備表示かなアメリカは猛ゲキ8月やセグチャネル前からちょっとしてと
思っているそうですねちょい一緒に静岡で十字を示してて塩ポッ代表増加の代表9ねっ
とかも一緒に行ったりして俺が負けてこれで買ったなぁ今止めて見てて黒際女性もなっ
た
あそい重ねてでチェック
ブービー一生線の動画アートパソコンぬファリャてるんですけど
世界一の両立という僕が何回やれば勝てるかっていうのを検証していきたいとおもい
ます
いやー良いですよ a year も世界ツインで何だろううんとかって言った
結局ここまで
ある中にうーん枯れないですねチャンネル分の1回も勝てたらそこで検証しているよう
でございます1回戦目です
もうしますお願いします組んだけっぽい
バックアイ50社いんあるこれでしょ
あいこでしょ
選考まではい
[音楽]
強い奴
5か入った
tar ています
[音楽]
あつったり直できてごとくたねーうーん
yeah
ん
それ
b
さあ皆さん
can
うん
1回目でチャンピオン映る香水なぜと窓どう戦っていくかポイントです私
やっぱバイクショップあっそ
食券スーパーフープねんっ
普通の僕ねあっ
[音楽]
うわぁ
はいオッケーです
ございます
やっぱりどのフェーズ
どうぞ
スタンバイ入っ
ff
うぇい
[音楽]
me
dea
rar あった
で
儲けたんだけどはい